the tricky thing with true identity
proofs is they're just endless
endless and there is no set of steps
that you can say oh you know you do step
one two three four and five and then you
get the answer at the bottom
you'll get i actually at school i got
given this sheet it has about 300
identity crews on it they all look
completely different doing one does not
help you do the next one and it's like
how am i supposed to wrap my head around
this
you need to recognize these things and
then notice they have happen in
different ways every single time so
don't expect how i've seen this question
before you have to have some overall
principles that will work for you no
matter what question you look at okay so
let's start with this one the strategy
that you can use no matter which
question you look at here's the first
thing that i will suggest and you may
have seen this already wherever you can
reduce
the identity you've got
to signs oops that should be an s
to sines and cosines we're really good
with dealing with sines and cosines
sometimes you look at a question you're
like this is just a mess because there's
a cosec a second all kinds of messy
things
if you can take those and bring them
down to come on actually while you're
coming in quiche get the latch and
clutch thanks
if you can bring out the sides and
cosines
more often than not things just sort of
come out in the wash okay now i will
point out
this or sometimes
make things
really long
right because to write sine theta over
cos theta takes more time and more space
than to write tan theta and the same
with every other identity that you use
so when you bring it down to the basic
functions something that starts like
this size will quickly blood out okay
but the point is once it's bigger you
can move around the pieces you can like
cancel oh there's a sign and there's a
sign so this is a very helpful strategy
overall okay
secondly
you need to recognize
the identities that i showed you
yesterday
and this comes somewhat from memory
really so the more you use these i mean
i taught a bit of a lie you know
sometimes one question looks completely
different another hey sir
yeah good side interrupt it's fine
at least another week or two on k12
really it's a disaster
i don't know if anyone's up been up near
the um the animals that are on the
basketball courts some of them are you
know how we're in the exam right you
know it's coming down um not all of them
animals fed as well as ours did and just
kept the rain out some let it do anyway
okay now i said
i said sometimes you do one identity and
the next one looks totally different
right so you're like what what use was
that okay well the point is the more you
use these the more these will sort of
form into your memory i've talked about
this before right
bless you
the reference sheet has a lot of the
identities that you will need okay but
if you are constantly looking at a
question and then looking at the
reference sheet and then looking back
and forth you will really struggle to
recognize the pieces that you need
because your brain's just in too many
pieces places at the same time okay so
recognize the known identity
then thirdly
don't
simplify randomly
so
again i mentioned this yesterday but i
want to re-emphasize it our brains are
geared to simplify you see thirds you
start rationalizing you see uh you know
things in brackets you start expanding
or whatever equivalent okay but when
you're trying to prove something
you're trying to go somewhere specific
not just the simplest form but a
particular kind of form whatever they
provide for you okay so in other words
don't simplify randomly
think about the goal
the way i always say this is have one
eye on the thing that you're
manipulating and then have your other
eye on well if i started with the
left-hand side i've got to get to the
right so look at the right-hand side
think what pieces do i need is that
thing one fraction or is it two what am
i sort of heading towards okay